hi my name is Derek Taylor I'm also
known at the LCS as that TSM guy and
I've basically been to every TSM game
since wildturtle subbed in 4k ox and the
beginning of season three guys pentakill
on Kalin and no matter where they went
I was not missing their games this was
the very first eSports scene I was
introduced to I seen it being built from
the ground up was nothing how it is
today and being able to be a part of
that been a humongous impact on my life
[Applause]
we're moments before the NA LCS 2018
summer finals where the best League of
Legends teams in North America will
compete for a chance to go to the
International World Championship it's
here where thousands of fans come
together to cheer for their favorite
teams experience the energy of the pack
stadium event and share their love of
the game my favorite team is Team Liquid
Team Liquid a double lift all the way
champions we know thousands of fans turn
up for finals and even more for worlds
but why do they do it
it's just not the same being at home and
washing it it's huge
half the energy of the crowd you have
everything going on I love the chanting
you know and all the stuff between the
games that you can't see from online I
mean everyone is so hyped it's like
shopping with them like chaining for
your you know your period team I always
meet the most incredible people when I
come to of it I've met with so many
people here that just because we have c9
that come in and we can start you know
talking means we definitely get along
and I decided a bunch of people on leak
from today and Israel my favorite thing
about the league community is it brings
you together like if you're into the
eSports aspect there's that if you're
into the creative aspect there's the
cosplay community it's just a really
great place to gather together with a
common interest I know like against like
a bad reputation that it's toxic like in
real life it's a bit offensive so
it's just great being a part of a
community where they all care about as
much as I do about
super-sick plays and and and the really
big games hearing people yell when a
gigantic play happens and getting some
deafened by a giant crowd the next is
open there is no defense cents carrot
shows up but the baseball
steamin
the Li community has some incredible
people supporting it from grassroots
community organizers to content creators
and casters you'd be hard-pressed to
find one of these people who doesn't
have a heartwarming story to tell
having a fan say hey back in 2013 X
happened and I loved it that blows my
mind that means that that person has
held on to that memory forever for
something we both love and he was able
to recall it to relive those moments
with somebody that had just as much
passion as I did when that call came out
is the most gratifying moment of this
job one of my favorite things to do with
my community when I'm done streaming is
to host somebody who has maybe like ten
or less viewers so many of my people
will like stick around and like make
this person's day who's been like
probably streaming for months with like
zero to no viewers at all it's just
really cool to see everybody like get
amped up for somebody else so I like to
go out and talk to the fans after the
games and there were these these two
kids are they they're probably 15 16 and
the girl walks up and she says hey are
you captain flowers I said yeah and she
was like will you take a picture with my
boyfriend he's too shy to ask you and he
doesn't want to feel like he's bothering
you as a dude who comes from small town
cornfield Ohio I still can't believe
that somebody would be that nervous to
ask for a picture
I'm still surprised people asked for a
picture with me to begin with and to
have somebody be that nervous like I
don't I took it as the most sincere girl
I'll never forget that to a bad guy I
don't remember her name but she gave me
a bharden huh she actually made one of
his little tiny meap's that he has
following him around so I still have
that but I think like my favorite thing
are typically like the letters like
where they like pour out their soul to
you on like something like a small note
and talk about like how big of a fan
they are like how much they support you
I think those are very like meaningful
so one time I was at I think Lone Star
clash and there was a fan that came up
came up to me and gave me a letter had
glitter on it that's why I really stood
out to me it said that like I was doing
a great job and you know
see like the person looked up to me and
they wish me the best in the future so I
would keep that letter with me and in
all its glitter in my LCS backpack it'll
travel with me to every event to LCS
stage every year and it was kind of the
reminder for me to not only stay
grounded but like what fans really meant
to me because I think without them and
without their support you know I would
have failed even earlier as a
professional player or as a stream where
and I would not be the person I am today
the people that have supported my
content when you look at like their
involvement with charity events the way
they've lifted up other content creators
and cosplay folks et cetera the
community is I think overall one of the
the best in gaming I will definitively
be a fan until League of Legends
disappears which I don't see that
happening in the next episode we're
taking a look at the place where the
next generation of Lika legends pros
train and compete the Academy League we
interview Academy casters coaches and
players about how the new infrastructure
is creating opportunities and stability
for those seeking to make a career in
eSports
[Music]